this is a production of cornell
university
uh good afternoon everybody
it's my pleasure to introduce bart of my
work at watkins lab during several years
and i will start my presentation with a
nice quote from the book chapter for
watkins and matthias
about the physiological disorders and
apple fruits apple fruit probably have
more documented physiological disorders
than any other horticultural crops
and indeed every year we investigate new
disorder especially
with
many new releasing cultivars
our work at watkins lab has focused on
number of research issues
like managing physiological disorder for
traditional and new health cultivars
studying the response of different apple
cultivars to anoxia and hypoxia
and development of non-destructive
models for dry matter soluble solids and
pigments
today i will as chris mentioned
just focused on
part of
my research which
i did at the watkins lab and i i had the
primary lead
on these trials
including honeycrisp gala and new york
too
first honeycrisp apple this is my
favorite cultivar
and i have a lot of publication on it
yeah why honeycrisp purple
based on this figure from the
usd market
it's clear
from the x axis the price per kilogram
for the
comparing two different cultivars and
the blue line is honeycrisp apple the
price range between 2.5 and four dollars
per kilogram and it was much higher
higher than any other cultivar
and in this article they named
honeycrisp as the queen of the u.s
market and indeed with this price it's
the queen of the market
however there are many physiological
disorders
facing
yes a lot of challenges here
like better bits of sugar breakdown
vascular browning wrinkly skin and too
many
but
most problematic being
soft skulled saggy breakdown and bitter
bit the first two disorders soft skull
and sega breakdown they are
low temperature disorders bitter bit is
high temperature disorder a nice
protocol has been developed in our lab
in 2004 by chris ital and
this protocol by conditioning fruit uh
for seven days at ten celsius then
before transferring to three cylinders
but and this is also like commercially
used or uh
the main
protocol in in industry
but this protocol unfortunately
excavates bitter bits in some fruits or
some susceptible oceans
and
as you know bitter bit
causes a lot of economic losses
and in this regard in 2015 we studied to
understand the
losses from the bitter bit we studied
two orthodox from western europe and the
effect of the storage temperature on the
last pier bin as dollars here in the
y-axis
and it's clear from the conditioning
conditioning plus three celsius it was
the highest
very high
loss from the bitter bit almost 330 and
by decreasing the storage temperature
almost the two horses were the same
around twenty dollars for that was very
important to look for methods to manage
and reduce the economic losses of losses
from the better bit and honeycrisp apple
back to 2013
when i have arrived cornell and the main
reason for me being at cornell here
because i was interested or still
interested in little bit
study and
honeycrisp is the best model for that
the first trial
we studied in 2013 was dynamic of little
bit ends of skull during storage and i
will present part of big trial we did
from two states pennsylvania and europe
different regions and i will focus only
on the western new york just for the
time we collected the fruit from 12
different oceans
the fruits started at three celsius and
here in the
y-axis the bitter bitter bit percentage
oath of skull percent we monitored and
assessed the
external disorder during four months of
storage and you find very nice we found
very nice result results that bitter bit
developed in the first two months of
storage from the 12 different authors
and soft skulls only started after the
first month of surge
and the results were consistent for the
other
reasons
we published the first publication in
extension in 2016 about honey crisp to
condition or not condition
many factors as
you know affect the
bitter bed development
be or both harvest
factors like soil composition the
location of the fruit on the trees
orchard block
and even the elevation of the food in
the same tree and in this model for the
non-linear partially square model
we just run the correlation uh between
the bitter bit as y and the maturity at
harvest as x's
in five different years
and after the model eliminating the
other factors because the correlation
was low the better bit correlated
positively with firmness and negatively
with internal acetylene concentration at
harvest and confirm that bitter bit
always consistent with less mature fruit
after these trials the importance
to find non-mineral prediction model for
the bitter bit in honeycrisp evil was
needed and we started these trials in
2016.
our objectives were
to evaluate non-mineral prediction model
compared to the mineral ones and to use
these predictions to reduce economic
losses by finding the best way to manage
a little bit after uh or during storage
i will present here also like the bar of
our work which we started in 2016.
we used three different methods passive
ethylene and magnesium the fruit from
that ear collected from two ortho blocks
and harvested the three weeks before
anticipated harvest and divide into
three different sets the best if no
chemicals just
the fruit kept at 20 celsius for 21 days
then the ethylene the fruit dipped with
solution or magnesium chloride solution
and we started the dynamic of the bitter
bit development during 21 days every two
or three days
if you see here from the passive and
ethereen almost the results were
consistent but for magnesium chloride
during the 21 days we couldn't
find in the beginning because the bitter
bit was low there is toxicity from the
magnesium to ride it was hard to
distinguish between the
death cells and between the bitter bits
occurrence for that
just like in the end of the storage we
were able to
classify them
then we we compared
the results from the best non-mineral
methods the three methods with the
actual bitter bits after storage from
the two orchards and it's clear here
also two was
or showed high bitter bits and the
results were consistent no significant
effect only the best submitted here
little bit was underestimation compared
to ethylene method
the summary from 2016 the first year all
the like i the the
three uh non-mineral methods
were higher in correlation compared to
the mineral uh from the three weeks
before harvest
and uh
be because as i mentioned the toxicity
from the magnesium method we decided to
eliminate this message we repeat it in
2017 the passive and deciding compared
to the mineral method and also we found
very good
or high correlation from this method
compared to minerals
and decided to go
just with the best method because it's
easy to apply straightforward doesn't
need any chemical
and we published the first publication
from the two years data in the extension
publication 2018.
in 2018
we
expanded the trail
to test the model across the new york
state and we use for that 38 different
uh oceans from three different regions
ports and valley western new york
champlain the best method as we said the
fruit harvested three weeks before
anticipated harvest the mineral
collected from the calyx end of the
fruit
uh
from three weeks before harvest also
another set at harvest time and the
storage temperature for the food uh for
actual harvest harvest or a commercial
harvest
sold at three celsius with or without
conditioning for seven days or at 0.5
celsius for four months
plus four days at room temperature
here the the part of our results in this
table the multivariate analysis
uh the correlation between the the
bitter bit from conditioning was three
services
compared with the predicted bitter bit
from passive or mineral from three weeks
or at harvest in conclusion the
correlation between the actual bitter
bit
again its passive was the highest
compared to the mineral method or the
ratios with calcium
the three years data were published in
scientific horticulture
also we updated our model for the
growers in 2020.
in
2019
and 2020 we expanded our
[Music]
work on the best model
to
validate the model across five states
including
uh
besides sorry the new york state
then i want to share with you a
conclusion about these results
from the year 1 and year 2 19 and 20 20.
in here when as it's clear here the
y-axis the bitter bit actual better bit
from
three celsius conditioning three celsius
or zero point five celsius and the
x-axis the predicted better bit from
basic model from three weeks before
harvest and it's clear
that
the
ontario canada fruit here
the fruit from the best moodle where
over estimation
unfortunately here the fruit were much
higher in the three weeks compared to
the actual
but in the washington
uh states
it was opposites
and underestimation the second year
unfortunately near two
fruits from one or from one region from
western new york which we used every
year for five years
showed similar trend to
washington state underestimation and we
don't know the reason yet we expect
there is effect of the bgrs but we are
not sure
the overall model from the two years
in this figure the passive 0.5 three
conditioning three celsius
just in conclusion or
bottom line
sorry
the
it's clear that the fruit from ontario
canada from the basin model were over
its estimation
during two years and from washington
state on the other hand opposite to the
ontario canada the other states were
consistent there is high correlation
between the actual and the predicted
little bit
in summary
we we have to
do more work to understand the effect of
bgrs on the our best model
also the results were promising for the
growers they can
reduce the economic clothes for the
growers and
as examples here based on our
best moodle if the bitter bit percentage
was higher than 30
then we
fruit shouldn't be
conditioned because it's dangerous and
shouldn't be also marketed immediately
until
all the bitter bits occurred
on the other hand if the
bitter bits from the best model was less
than 10 percent
the food can be marketed immediately
immediately
the
other work to understand as i said the
effects of the bgrs on the beta model we
tested
retain
amino ethoxy vinyl glycine or harvester
this
sprayable con
[Music]
compound of the one methyl cyclopropene
on
now i will present on uh
honeycrisp and later on
but first i want to explain
the
work or the physiology of the effect of
both retain or harvest on ethylene
pathway
when we spray avg it plugs the acc cyan
phase in the ethereum best way the mcb
it
blocks the receptors of the ethylene and
this is non-reversible plaque both
hormones delay through tribening and
expand harvest sundu and prevent fruit
drop
and they are also as you know
commercially used
the first trial about honeycrisp
we
studied the effect of brie and both
harvest application of missile
psychopathy one mcb
to understand the on the physiological
disorders and our main goal was to
understand the effect of the bgrs in
relation to also passive method our
model
the experiment done by
uh untreated fruit control or fruit
treated two weeks before harvest
standard early one week before harvest
standard late one and two weeks before
harvest distributed
one week before harvest double rate
and
because like most of these
treatments showed similar results
in effects compared to control i will
present the data from the first
treatment from the two weeks before
harvest
the other application was the post
harvest mcp application food as the
manufacturing recommendation
just pulled overnight and mcb
has been done or was applied sorry for
on the fruit as one microlitre bill
liter
after the mcb the fruit started at three
celsius with conditioning or continuous
0.5 celsius for five months plus
four days at 20 celsius
i i'll present part of the data
including the better bit here
the better bit percentage in the y-axis
in the x-axis the treatments control or
harvester and
the bars red bar mcb and no mcb it's
clear here from the results the
harvester
induced more little bits
and mcb opposites the most harvest mcb
reduce the bitter bit during the storage
it means like the bree harvest and both
harvests of the mcb world obviously
for the leather blood is the new
disorder
it's consistent usually with little bit
the leather blotch
enhanced with the post harvest mcp
application significantly
for the soft skull
we stored the fruit here at 0.5 and
conditioning plus 3 celsius and
the reason for storing at 0.5 to see the
effect on inducing the temperature of
the soft skull because usually soft
skull is low temperature
disorder
then the surprising thing here the
harvester reduced
significantly the
soft skull development but no no effect
of the post-harvest application of the
mcb on development of the disorder
to understand the relation between the
bitter with soft skull
between the storage temperature and the
pgrs the pre-harvest pgrs we run the
non-linear
partially square model here in the a
just briefly we use the
variable important plot against the
coefficient
this model
any factor less than 0.8 can eliminate
it from the model
and
in this figure here the partial
correlation between x and y
the better bit correlated positively
with the green color ieg value
with tighter table acidity and
negatively with internally seeing
concentration and the starch pattern
index at harvest
on the other hand the stem and soft
skull
where
was correlated in the
positively with iec starch pattern index
and negatively with green color and
firmness with more material fruit
in conclusion
the pre-harvest mcb increased the risk
of little bits for that our
recommendation is very clear here
if the best model gives high prediction
of the bitter bit then the brs shouldn't
be apply for this block it's very
dangerous
and the incidence of the leather blast
was increased by the bush harvest mcb
treated and also like we can know that
from the best model because the two
disorders are correlated
soft skull
is a common low temperature was reduced
significantly by the brie harvest mcb
treatment
we published this work in post-harvest
biology and technology
and
nice publication was
the second
cultivar i'm going to present today is
gayle
and again why gayle is
is important apple cultiva because gala
is number one apple in the us
and uh now in new york the production
is expanding
the biggest limitation for the gala
production and storage or marketing stem
in the flesh browning development
for those not familiar with the disorder
stem in the flesh browning is relatively
new new disorder in the gay lab
the
disorder starts in the sim in area and
through the time expands
through the flesh and
the core in severe cases
and beyond to the clinic's end
we know from previous studies at our lab
that the
less mature fruit
always
gives less
some inflation browning for that here
the objective from this study was to to
study the the effect of retain
at at closer
spray time to the harvest compared with
harvester and the company just was
asking us company uh questions about
the ability to apply retain close to the
harvest and still
reduce the stem and the flesh browning
and gives the good color red color
compared to harvest or control
and
we harvested here the in 2020 the
treatment was or the experiment in the
three harvest times the first harvest
september 8
september 15 and 22.
the fruit started for four or eight
months
in controlled atmospheric storage at two
percentage uh o2 and one percent co2 at
0.5 celsius
also like just representing the part of
the stem in the flesh browning from our
results
in the y-axis here
and here the removals four and eight
months the harvest times three harvest
times and the treatments
in that 2020 the browning in general was
very low compared to this year this year
is really high browning we we got so far
and after four months of storage no
browning they were even at control
but after eight months
it's clear
that the
internal browning or stem in the fresh
browning increased by advancing fruit
maturity or but advancing harvest time
but
there was no effect of the other
treatment on the development of the stem
and the fleshy browning except
one treatment here the
retain
full rate
after before one day of harvest in the
harvest too
then again we run our lovely model here
for the bls
to understand the effect of the stem in
the flesh bounding against the food
maturity at harvest and confirmed
its correlation with internal clean
concentration and negativity with ied
firmness in relation to the removal
times and the harvest time as well
in conclusion from that trail
we
all the
retained all this
space time will retain inhibited respect
for the first browning development
for food storage at eight months is
except as i mentioned the one
harvest
the late spray of retain appears to be
affected as harvester but the
confirmation is needed
as i mentioned before this year we got
more browning compared to last year this
year is really browning here
the next trial we did from this year
2021
about to investigate the effects of the
bgr's retain with the ied value just to
show you what the same color
on the stem and the fleshy browning
the fruit where untreated or treated
would retain
21 days before harvest half rate
harvested in one time
the uh september 14 because everything
this year was completely horrible for
the harvest and like very fast and
early at harvest we use the d emitter
difference absorbance this machine for
those also not familiar with the machine
it measures the chlorophyll in range of
670 and 720 nanometer
and reflects the
the measures the global feel or the
green color in the skin surface
the reading usually range from zero to
five
and enable from zero to two
just back to our trial on the emitter we
classify the foot as 0.2 difference
between the fruit
and after that fruit started at
controlled atmospheric storage two
percentage o2 and one percent co2 for
five months but seven days at 20 celsius
the results here for the stem interface
browning was really interested here
interesting
just to mention for the control fruit
because the fruit will advance in
maturity only we were able to find one
category of the
ied value here
for control 0.2
but for retain the food we are
classified from 0 to 0.8
in conclusion the controlled food showed
high
same in the flesh browning
as almost like 100
from five months
while retain the same category from the
da
reduce the same and flash problem to the
health almost
by increasing the ied value the stem and
flash problem was reduced completely was
inhibited at 0.6 to 0.8
our conclusion here high correlation
between stem interface browning and food
maturity the retain reduced some
inflation browning at the same ied
category compared with control and
increasing the ied value decreased the
stem and flash browning
the last
cultivar for to do today is new york to
apple
the production of the new york to apple
based or on the crunch time apple
growers
reaches 175 000 bushels
and
the importance of this cultivar now
working on it because we need or the
industry need
for long time storage and also they use
it for fresh cut fruit
i will discuss one problem here about
managing stress water core in new york
to abba
and
briefly
the stress water core compared to normal
water court in fuji or other cultivars
like yuna gold
the the fruit in fuji and example the
water core
exactly as the name in the water area
and the vascular bundles but for the
stress water core the sorbitol from the
uh
sores the leaf
under high temperature in in
the
end of the season and uh cool nights
it uh couldn't like the stress under the
cells the sorbitol and saccharos
couldn't enter the cells and accumulate
in the intercellular area outside of the
cells and makes this
appearance
as glassy watery
we have to manage the stress water core
before the storage because if we didn't
do that especially uh for restoring in
the controlled atmosphere storage at low
storage temperature
in the beginning these like enter silver
very low
air in them
and
under low oxygen storage
the water cooled down and flash browning
can be developed
which is causes a lot of losses for the
warehouses and the storage
we used our
nice chart from 2016 we developed our
lab
for the stress water core in new york
two zero no watercolor and five as here
is completely sucked with watercolor and
this is horizontal view and vertical
view
the
experiment which i'm going to present
now about the effect of the bgrs on the
water core
or stress water core dissipation
from the references we know that the
water core
in relation to the bgrs
studied before there is like a lot of
studies about it or not a lot there are
some studies about this topic but
the
effect of the bgrs on the water core
dissipation is completely new
for that we started our first trial in
2019
applying harvesta
on juno gold apple and i will
just present parts of the work about the
stress water core dissipation
and here if we see a fruit treated or
not with with harvester
and the
after uh
harvest the food stored at 20 celsius
for 30 days at
20 celsius at room temperature or 20
celsius and we we
check the water cooler or assist the
water core development
nice reduction and dissipation of water
core was
came from
the
harvester treatment compared to control
always the food quality were very high
and here i'm not presenting them
and we
published our nice work here the first
work
in
post-harvest biology and technology and
also like bill miller helped us in
the sugar analysis
in 2020 based on our results we
repeated the trial on the new 2 to
see the effects of both retain or
harvest the spray on water core
dissipation
then the fruit were treated or not was
retained harvested 17 days before
anticipated harvest and the fruit
harvested in october 20
fruits were stored in three different
temperatures 3 10 20 celsius
and assists at 0 5 10 16 20 and 30 days
intervals
bottom line from the results here
at three different temperatures
and the
stress water core represents
on the
y-axis
in conclusion the the harvester
at harvest time reduced the water cool
percentage compared to retain and
control
for the effect of the storage
temperature
retain
was nicely
reduced the
water cool during the storage at three
sensors or 10 sensors compared with
control but no effect was found at a
higher temperature at 20 celsius
then our conclusion also for that was
the no effect of retain compared with
harvester
in the incidence of watercolor at
harvest and watercolor reduction was
high with retain at three or ten celsius
but at higher storage temperature there
is no effect compared to control
from the beginning because harvester
reduced the watercolor at harvest there
was no effect harvested during the
storage
the ongoing
work now nice work with
our students or the student
xiang his master student our lab and
those who bark his bose duck in our lab
with a collaboration with lillian sheng
and his team
about completing the effect of bgr's on
quarter core dissipation
and also our work has been published
here in or republish our work in
extension of the casing from the two
years
in the end
i want to thank
our great team
with the great leadership and support by
chris
our lovely
phd and master students postdocs
the
visiting scholars from all around the
world
and technician also many thanks to the
guild here at cornell susan leyland
terence brick bill miller and kevin
also
many thanks to
mike brown
always like the lab open for us
and also
for the collaborators from the growers
the
storage operators the commercial
horticultural team at cornell
cooperative extension
our funders the new york research and
development
new york farm viability and nifa
multi-state project nifa organic
transition project
thank you so much for your
for your attention
and please ready for any question
yes so um you described the passive
method for
determining bitter pit um can you
describe what that passive method is a
little bit more
yeah the best method uh it's
the food
yes come here and repeat the questions
okay
sorry thank you chris
uh just neil has asked about the
ex
explaining about the passive model
uh the best method the food harvested
from uh three weeks before anticipate
harvest
and the fruit like the number where we
use around 100 randomly from different
trees and uh
from different blocks
but i mean for every block we use 100
fruit the food stored for 20 celsius
three weeks
before harvest the day before harvest or
at harvest the fruit will assist for the
external bitter bit development and the
percentage were calculated and based on
the percentage from five years
model we have calculation about the
expectation later in the
storage it means if the prediction was
low moderate or high what our
recommendation will be as i present this
year for the growers
after that three week period of visual
inspection right and you count the the
percent exactly you have the equations
right well thank you yeah
thanks for your seminar uh part of this
i guess is um
is
a seminar for a promotion for you
and so if you um were to be promoted can
you tell us a little bit about
future activities or plans like what new
um ideas
uh do you have for the post harvest lab
thank you so much for the great question
uh
if i've been promoted i will
focus first
as primarily on able fruit because it's
the main every crop in new york and i
hope to develop a post harvest vegetable
program at cornell and bring fun for
that
and stay also like beside that in in
coordination with chris and our uh
colleagues from the vista vegetable
program at cornell
i'm looking to work on new technology
developing nanoparticles
in relation to post harvest application
and also
some
[Music]
degradable biofilms works for the
modified atmospheric storage
uh to also like protect the environment
with for the environment for sustainable
agricultural production
this also like needs to be in
collaboration with different colleagues
from different schools
yeah welcome
yes if we really enjoyed your seminar
thank you um
so for honeycrisp bitter pit
harvista
application
enhances bitter pit
you have the same chemical if you apply
if you apply it after harvest
the ymcp
reduces bitter pit
can you think of a mechanism a unified
mechanism if there's any
yes this is also a great question
uh
the harvest is said like any factor
induce
the ethylene
before harvest
it's if sorry after harvest it's
increased the bit as conditioning
conditioning like after after harvest
because the metabolism increased
everything the ethylene is high then the
bitter bit uh improved for mcb after
storage it's inhibited the inhibits the
ethylene
wart then the bitter bit will be uh
will be low from the after harvest from
the bree harvest any factor effects on
the
make the fruit less mature
effects obviously that means the calcium
accumulation the minerals inside the
fruit will be less than the material
fruit and will be
induced more a little bit after the
storage and as you said the mechanism is
very clear that this the pre-harvest
application completely makes less
material fruit than induced a bitter bit
and also the our models from the
correlation between bitter bit and the
fruit maturity shows similar trend
always better bits at harvest
is
like compared to the correlate with less
material fruit
but
in open side conditioning always
enhances the occurrence
yeah thank you so much for the great
question we have a chatbot's question
from kevin yes have you noticed any
location growing regent effects on
stress induced waterfall
yeah actually like most our work in the
stress water core
was focused now on uh
location from geneva and cornell
orchards
and
the
just my question briefly here we found
different uh
relation between the weather during the
story the years that mean the ear effect
it was really
like huge
in 2016 because the weather was warm
during the
harvest season or the ripening season
the watercolor stress watercolor was
very high
last year also the same
if the watercolor was very high in the
beginning when the temperature increased
in 2020 but after that
it became normal or reduced
yeah no no any uh
study about the original effect of
stress watercouriet
any other question
all right thank you joseph for a very
fine thank you so much thank you thank
you everybody
thank you for coming
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu